welcome back you know so much has
changed in the last year a year ago the
White House was complaining that there
was too much sex in Hollywood so
times change a billion people are
watching us tonight except for Linda
Tripp who's taping it is it just me does
she look like Michael Caine and dressed
to kill
am i right think about it
am I now here is a woman I married in
Woody Allen's deconstructing Harry if
the shoe fits introduce her ladies and
gentlemen elisabeth shue
whoever said you can't make a silk purse
out of a sow's ear never met a
motion-picture costume designer the
resourceful artists who designed the
astonishing array of costumes for the
five nominated films last year are Ruth
e Carter for the drama of 19th century
African struggling for their rightful
place in America in Steven Spielberg's
Amistad Dante Ferretti who brought the
colorful beauty and mysticism of the Far
East to Martin Scorsese's epic Kingdom
Janet Patterson for a delineation of
nineteenth-century styles worn by the
stylish cast of Gillian Armstrong's
Oscar and Lucinda
Debra L Scott for her authentic
recreation of the multitude of clothing
worn by the passengers of history's most
disastrous boat ride James Cameron's
Titanic and Sandy Powell whose gorgeous
costumes helped bring to life Henry
James turn-of-the-century novel he named
Sophie's the wings of the dough and the
Oscar goes to Debra L Scott for Titanic
Debra L Scott is working costume design
on more than 20 films including legends
of appalling et this is her first
Academy Award
Academy I'm deeply honored to accept
this award on the behalf of David Ave
Beth coningsburgh lolly poor Matt right
Smith Dale ribbon Dominic Girardi gene
gold and the rest of my remarkable
costume crew their dedication talent
friendship and guidance helped fulfill
my dream to bring the spirit of Titanic
and her passengers to life
thank you Jim Cameron for the
first-class passage thanks John Landau
and Ray Santini for such fine navigation
for my parents my husband and finally my
two daughters Tess and Hana whose beauty
is my greatest inspiration thank you
and the best thing is those costumes are
drip dry in
I feel so good